what we're going to do in this video is
try to get a graphical appreciation for
inflection points which we also cover in
some detail in other videos
so the first thing to appreciate is an
inflection point is a point on our graph
where our slope goes from decreasing to
increasing or from increasing to
decreasing so right over here i have the
graph of some function and let me draw
the slope of a tangent line at different
points so when x is equal to negative 2
that's it that is what the tangent line
looks like and you could see its slope
and then as we increase x we can see
that the slope is positive but it is
decreasing
then it goes to 0 and then it goes
negative and the slope keeps decreasing
all the way until we get it looks like
we get to about x equals negative 1
and then our slope begins to increase
again
so something interesting happened right
at x equals negative 1. and so that's a
pretty good indication we're just doing
it graphically here we're not proving it
but that at this point right over here
we have an inflection point so let me
write that down so let me
show you that again now that with a
point is labeled for x at negative 2 we
have a positive slope it decreases
decreases decreases it's negative it
still decreases
x equals negative 1 and then our slope
begins increasing again so that's how
you could tell it just from the function
itself but you could also
tell inflection points by looking at
your first derivative remember an
inflection point is when our slope goes
from increasing to decreasing or from
decreasing to increasing the derivative
is just the slope of the tangent line so
this right over here this is the
derivative of our original blue function
so here we can see the interesting parts
and so notice what's happening on the
derivative
our the derivative is decreasing which
means the slope of our tangent line of
our original function is decreasing and
we saw that
notice while the derivative is
decreasing right over here our slope
will be decreasing our slope is positive
our slope is positive but decreasing
then it becomes negative but decreasing
all the way until this point which is at
x equals negative 1.
so let's do that again so our slope is
positive and decreasing
and then right over
about there
right over here our slope keeps
decreasing but then it actually turns
negative
and it keeps decreasing all the way
until x equals negative 1.
and then our slope begins increasing
again so the derivative begins
increasing which means the slope of our
tangent line of our original function
begins increasing
so that point is interest interesting an
inflection point one way to identify an
inflection point from the first
derivative is to look at a minimum point
or to look at a maximum point because
that shows a a place where your
derivative is changing direction it's
going from increasing to decreasing or
in this case from decreasing to
increasing which tells you that this is
likely an inflection point
now let's think about the second
derivative
so right over here this is the
derivative of the derivative
and i could zoom out to look at the
whole thing you actually can't see the
whole thing right over here actually i
can zoom out a little bit more so that
you can really see what's going on
and so what's interesting here well it
looks like right at x equals negative 1
we cross our second derivative crosses
the x axis so let me label that so right
over there we cross the x axis which is
exactly where we have the inflection
point and that makes sense because our
if our second derivative goes from being
negative to positive that means our
first derivative goes from being
decreasing to increasing which means the
slope of our tangent line of our
function goes from decreasing to
increasing we've seen that over and over
decreasing to increasing right over here
now it's important to realize the second
derivative doesn't need to just touch
the x-axis it needs to cross it so you
might say well what about this point
right over here
2 comma 0. the second derivative touches
the x-axis there
but it doesn't cross it so we never go
from our derivative increasing to our
derivative decreasing
so big takeaways you can figure out the
inflection point from either the graph
of the function from the graph of the
derivative or the graph of the second
derivative on the function itself you
just want to inspect the slopes of the
tangent line and think about where does
it go from decreasing to increasing or
the other way around from increasing to
decreasing
if you're looking at the first
derivative you really just want to look
at minimum or maximum points and if
you're looking at the second derivative
which we have in orange you want to look
at what x value are we crossing the
x-axis not just touching it but crossing
the x-axis